ladies and gentlemen performing together
for the first time ever please give a
warm welcome to the 30 Rock
[Applause]
[Music]
Orchestra
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
that was so cool that was so cool thank
you that was so cool thank you oh my God
that was amazing we are such a big F
thank you for
doing oh my God I can't you later I'm
going to hug
you dude Jill job thank you for doing
this oh my God give it
[Music]
up that was
inredible
I love that more instrumentals here that
was so cool welcome to the Kelly
Clarkson show everybody our New York
City to Wonderland is up and running as
well once again give it up for our 30
Rock Orchestra along with my band
y'all we have from Late Night with Seth
Myers Fred Armon on
guitar from The Tonight Show starring
Jimmy Fallon it's Mar Kelly on Bas and
James poer on the
KE and from Saturday Night Live it's
Maddy rice on guitar and Ron Blake on
the float give it
on was so cool that was the holiday
classic Christmas Eve Saro by trans
suban Orchestra I love listening to that
and that was our first ever all
instrumental kellyoke this was actually
Jason's idea I you're the one who
introduced me to this song like years
on I was like i' never really heard it
and I was like this is incredible why
did you want to do this well I mean best
part about being at 30 Rock is being
surrounded by so many great musicians I
mean they're above us around us all
around and yeah James never talks to me
in the hallway so I figured the only way
to get him here was to be so now we're
changing numbers it's all good no just I
couldn't couldn't wait to have everybody
in the building so thank you guys so
much oh man so cool you're so gifted
thank you so much for taking the time
like we know that you have your other
shows to get to because everybody's
working um so everybody they're not
going to see the whole hour so please
give it up them one more
time thank you all so
much y' 30 Rock is so cool I love
working here it's so
[Music]
cool
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home